Hilary Clinton is back she announced on
Tuesday that she takes responsibility
for losing the 2016 presidential
election of Donald Trump sort of
according to the newly defined former
Democratic leader
she takes quote absolute personal
responsibility for her loss but she adds
that quote I was on the way to winning
until a combination of Jim Comey's
letter on October 28th and Russian
WikiLeaks raised doubts in the minds of
people who are inclined to vote for me
and got scared off if the election had
been on October 27th I would be your
president but aside from that she takes
responsibility she also added the places
that didn't vote for her couldn't get
quote cell coverage for a mile um no
what does she have going on next she
says I'm now back to being an activist
citizen and part of the resistance
really what exactly is she resisting
this rogue one she dragged her party
down almost single-handed in the in the
last election cycle now she wants to be
part of the cool kids crowd again this
is precisely what's wrong with Hillary
Clinton and what her husband understood
you can't hijack a popular movement with
which you had nothing to do Bernie
Sanders maybe
Hillary Clinton knew but perhaps Hillary
still has 20/20 ambitions those rumors
are still floating out there and right
now the three leading 20/20 candidates
for the Democrats are all around her age
Elizabeth Warren who's a young 67 Joe
Biden 74 years old and Bernie Sanders
who's 75 years old she is a youthful 69
what's to stop her from running again
herein lies the problem for the
Democrats all of their top names are old
fogies with no youth appeal other than
the geriatrics not so socialists who
isn't technically a Democrat their youth
movement however has no exact target
it's just a lot of people angry about a
lot of different things complaining
about the evils of patriarchal
heterosexist cysts normative society
hillary cannot lead that bunch
republicans should be very excited to
see hillary back in play just so they
should be excited that barack obama's
making a comeback obama and hillary
helped raise a generation of democrats
now those salty earth i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
okay done this to talk about today I
want to talk at length about Jimmy
Kimmel's pitch for Obamacare last night
on his program and what it meant to me
because I think have some personal
experience in this area that is relevant
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at zip recruiter comm so
if you don't want to be cursed with a
with the blight of horrible employees
like some of us I could then are then
you should go over to zip recruiter comm
right now and check it out you can post
your job to a hundred-plus job sites you
get all of the resumes into one place
you can file through them there you
don't have to worry about them stacking
up on your desk enough to worry about
calling back it's all done just with one
click of a button you find candidates in
any city or industry nationwide just
post one to watch your qualified
candidates roll in that zip recruit our
easy to use interface no juggling emails
or call to your office you screen
candidates you rate them and you hire
the right person fast you want to make
sure that you have the best person for
the job zip recruiter is the way to do
it it's been used by Fortune 100
companies and it's been used by the
daily wire right now my listeners can
post jobs on zip recruiter for free
right now now going to zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire that is zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire make
sure you use that daily wire so they
know that we sent you again you can post
those jobs for free and make sure that
you're getting me best qualified
applicants because most people are never
going to hear your job opening unless
you put it on zip recruiter networks
like Facebook and Twitter you can put it
on there just with one click makes your
job easy make sure you get the best
applicants if recruiter comm slash of
daily wire okay so the talk of the town
yesterday was Jimmy Kimmel on late-night
and he was telling a story about his son
he has a newborn son who tragically has
a heart condition and he was brought to
Children's Hospital he had to have
emergency heart surgery I guess who's
born maybe at Children's Hospital or at
least they transferred him over there
and human Kimmel tells the story and
then he turns into a pitch for Obamacare
and I want to talk about this because I
have some personal thoughts on the
matter a little over a week ago on
Friday April 21st my wife Molly gave
birth to a boy baby boy and he appeared
to be a normal healthy baby until about
three hours after he was born when a
very attentive nurse at cedars-sinai
hospital
her name is nunu she was checking him
out and heard a murmur in his heart
which is common with newborn babies but
she also noticed
he was a bit purple he did an x-ray and
his lungs were fine which meant his
heart wasn't so now more doctors and
nurses and equipment come in and it's
it's a terrifying thing I'm up you know
my wife is back in the recovery room she
has no idea what's going on and I'm
standing in the middle of a lot of very
worried looking people kind of like
right now we were trying to figure out
what the problem is it's Friday night
and so they call a pediatric
cardiologist dr. Evans on they did an
echocardiogram which is a sonogram of
the heart and found that Billy was born
with a heart disease something called
tetralogy of hello with pulmonary
atresia it's hard to explain basically
the pulmonary valve was completely
blocked and he has a hole in the wall
between the left and right sides of his
heart and then they brought my wife in
and they wheeled her in and doctors on
told her what was going on what our
options were we decided to take him to
Children's Hospital where there's a
world-renowned cardiac surgeon who was
by all accounts a genius his name is dr.
von Starnes so we put the baby in an
ambulance the Children's Hospital Los
Angeles and on Monday morning dr.
Starnes opened his chest and fixed one
of the two defects of his heart and went
in there with a scalpel and did some
kind of magic that I couldn't even begin
to explain he open the valve and the
operation was a success it was the
longest three hours of my life and I
have a list of people I want to thank
for making that happen and I hope I have
my list these are just some of the
people who played a part in this it was
an enormous team effort really was at
and I want to see one other thing
President Trump last month proposed a
six billion dollar cut in funding to the
National Institute of Health and thank
God our congressman made a deal last
night to not go along with that they
actually increased funding by two
billion dollars ten of the people who
would have been affected by those cuts
of the National is due to help our
children and it would have a major
impact on a lot of great places
including Children's Hospital Los
Angeles which
so unbelievably sad to me we were
brought up to believe that we live in
the greatest country in the world but
until a few years ago millions of
millions of us had no access to health
insurance at all
you know before 2014 if you were born
with congenital heart disease like my
son was there was a good chance you'd
never be able to get health insurance
because he had a pre-existing condition
you were born with a pre-existing
condition if your parents didn't have
medical insurance you might not live
long enough to even get denied because
of a pre-existing condition if your baby
is going to die and it doesn't have to
it shouldn't matter how much money you
make that I think that's something now
whether you're a Republican or Democrat
or something else we all agree on that
right I mean okay so I have some
experiences here now to talk about them
and I don't really talk about this a lot
because I don't like to make my family
life an issue on the show and in
politics generally okay a couple of
years ago this have been mid of 2015 my
daughter was born in January 2014 mid
2015 like July 2015 my daughter who is a
beautiful little girl she is she is she
has the flu and she starts throwing up
and when she's throwing up she same
thing and we don't know why and so we
take her into the very scary room and
she's like Keeling over literally
fainting dead away while she's throwing
up and it turns out that it was
breath-holding we didn't know that so we
go to the ER and they do a bunch of
tests on her and one of the tests they
do is they run an EKG on her and they
say the EKG looks basically normal but
we just want to have some follow-up send
us to a cardiologist and the
cardiologist takes a second look and
does an ultrasound then tells us that
she has a heart murmur not just a heart
murmur it's actually such a large hole
in Harsha in atrial septal defect nasty
and she had a heart murmur that was so
you couldn't hear it because the hole in
her heart was so large that he couldn't
actually normally the heart murmur comes
from you hear the blood flowing the
wrong way through the heart you couldn't
hear it because the hole was so large in
her heart so in August of last year she
had to or in August of 2015 rather she
had to have open-heart surgery the
surgeon was dr. Vaughn Starnes exactly
the same surgeon who worked on Jimmy
Kimmel's kid it was at Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles could not be
more grateful to Children's Hospital LA
or dr. Starnes who is indeed the
master of his craft there's a reason
he's the best in the world and we were
lucky enough to be able to to work with
him and he obviously did the work and
saved our daughter's life I mean she she
wouldn't have died immediately wasn't
like an emergency situation quite as
much as Jimmy Kimmel's Ketut sounds like
but she would have had feller to thrive
as she got older she would have had to
have open-heart surgery
I think they hadn't detected it would
have shorter lifespans his you know 30
or 40 now they fixed it she's good as
new
thank God everything is fine and she's
great the reason that I tell this story
is because when Jimmy Kimmel starts
talking about the National Institutes
for health and federal funding and
health insurance and all the rest of us
the reason that I was able to get great
coverage for my kid is because I was
employed and also because my wife and I
had health insurance long before we had
a kid he's missing a couple of key
points here and I wanted to establish
sort of the bonafide he's here so I'm
speaking about so I'm not speaking from
the perspective of someone who hasn't
experienced nearly identically what
Jimmy Kimmel has experienced here it was
absolutely terrifying when you go and
you meet with the doctor and the doctor
tells you your kid you know even if the
doctor says it's a surgery that's done
regularly it's still frightening as all
hell because they're cracking open your
kid's chest and cutting or open and and
you know it was in hooking or tubes it
was really terrifying and horrifying and
thank god she's okay but the point is
that when he immediately connects that
to federal funding when he commedia
connected to Obamacare I don't like the
process as a general rule I don't like
the process of using personal stories
like this to push for legislation or to
push for public policy because it
doesn't necessarily follow and what I
mean by this is again dr. Starnes great
doctor children hospital grade hospital
most of the people when we were in
Children's Hospital during the recovery
we were in the ICU for about a week when
we were in Children's Hospital most of
the people who are in Children's
Hospital I know this because my wife
rotated through Children's Hospital
because she's a doctor in the LA area a
huge number of the kids in Children's
Hospital are not kids who have great
insurance many of them don't have any
insurance the fact is that in the United
States of America if you have an
emergency situation like Jimmy Kimmel
had let's just assume this happened at
cedars-sinai again where my wife gave
birth let's assume that the exact in
situation happened but there was no
insurance and doctor spotted that there
was this emergency surgery that had to
happen
in order to prolong the child's life
they don't ask insurance they
immediately send the kid over to
Children's Hospital and dr. Starnes
works on the kid because and then
somebody else fills the gap Children's
Hospital is very lucky and the
Children's has enormous sums of giving
people give tons of money to Children's
Hospital I'm sure Jimmy Kimmel will too
we giving charity to Children's Hospital
people there's a whole wall an entire
wall in Children's Hospital that is just
names of celebrities who have given
money to Children's Hospital to help
support Children's Hospital people are
generous with their giving people want
to save people who are in need the
problem with the argument that we have
to cover pre-existing conditions which
is basically what Jimmy Kimmel is saying
here is number one when it comes to
children it is the job of the parents to
have health insurance when the kid is
born because the parents health
insurance covers the kid right the fact
is that my kid was not buying her own
health insurance when she was a year and
a half old we had health insurance it
covered her that doesn't mean that if
there's a gap that we as a community
shouldn't step in that's what charities
for that's why hospitals cover the gap
that's why costs are passed on very
often through a backdoor method via the
hospital to people who do have insurance
but it does say that it is a mistake as
a society to simply say to people that
there is no moral responsibility to get
health insurance well you're healthy
well you don't have health problems
because if you don't do that if there if
you just say whenever you get sick you
can immediately take advantage of the
system people will wait to get sick to
take advantage of the system and you
will end up bankrupt things of the
system the reason the children's is so
great is because children get paid lots
of money they get paid lots and lots and
lots of money to do these sorts of
things dr. Starnes I'm sure millions of
dollars a year and he deserves every
penny that he makes and he's able to do
that because there are people paying
voluntarily into health insurance to
cover themselves so when something bad
happens he gets paid dr. Starnes is not
somebody who should be working for 60
grand a year like a postal worker if you
do that to the health system you're not
going to be able to get the kinds of
surgeries that dr. Starnes provides or
the kind of care that Children's
Hospital provides and I think it's
deeply important that when we talk about
everybody getting the sort of care that
you make a most kid got or that my kid
gets in order for that to happen you
have to make it affordable and quality
the only thing that does that is a free
market and again that doesn't mean there
shouldn't be a safety net provided by a
society and I'm talking about through
government now I'm talking about through
charity and through communities and
through charity hospitals all of that is
true but to use a personal situation
that is really difficult and
breaking in order to promulgate a public
policy that actually doesn't achieve
what you're seeking to achieve children
is not worthwhile Children's Hospital
could not be what Children's Hospital is
if it existed is a public sector
Hospital unless you are willing to tax
people up the wazoo and that sort of
taxation scheme bankrupt countries and
doesn't provide the same care anyway
look at the National Health Service in
Britain or the or the nationalized
health care service in Canada this is
the I have nothing but sympathy for
Jimmy Kimmel because I've been through
as I say exactly the same thing and it's
heartbreaking and that heartbreak should
not be used as a political tool in order
to push a political agenda and I'm sure
that Jimmy Kimmel believes have reward
that he's saying but funding for the
National Institutes of Health has
nothing to do with what happened here
again the American people are insanely
generous the amount of research that
goes into the sorts of techniques that
dr. Starnes used is tremendous and it's
not from the public sector and most in
the most part it's actually from the
private sector ok so I wanted to get
that out of the way before I go on here
going to talk about Mayday and what the
left is showing of itself and then I
want to talk about the Trump budget
before I get to any of that I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so my Patriots apply if
you are deeply concerned about what's
going on in the world right now you need
to talk to my friends over at my Patriot
supply and I'm about to tell you why
nobody at this office is prepared for
any sort of emergency of any kind you
know I asked Mathis the other day what
would happen if there was like an EMP
attack by North Korea or an earthquake
or a zombie outbreak you have a
flashlight or potable water what we do
and his answer was we need Austin yep
no preparedness no going hungry for even
a day no percent in trouble Chiapas
Austin Edom my suggestion was slightly
less severe we should probably drop ten
bucks on like a wireless radio and stock
up on some delicious emergency meals
from my Patriot supply they taste like
home cooking and get a four week supply
for just 99 bucks and prepare with been
calm they will even cover the shipping
they'll make sure you're safe your
family safe prepare with Ben calm your
life might depend on it especially
apparently if you work with Mathis
Mathis is you know and it is hard to
work for when the maps of time I had you
above the disc cartoon has mapped as a
ser precisely correct it's eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
prepare with Ben calm if you want that
four-week emerge
the food supply for just 99 bucks it's
something that you owe to yourself if
you're worried about natural disaster or
if you are worried about some sort of
governmental disaster of any kind check
it out prepare with Ben dot-com okay so
yesterday was of course May Day the the
winning internet meme of the day goes of
course to Justin Timberlake who
immediately tweeted out hey guys it's
May which is amazing for people who
don't remember the days of in sync and
it's May then then you've missed out in
any case the the communist Madia decided
that it was a perfect time to go out and
rampage and loot things demonstrating of
course the tolerance is the greatest
attribute of the people on the left
here's what it looked like at the
protest in in Portland and breaking news
made a protest going on right now in
several cities including Los Angeles in
Washington State things started getting
violent in Portland we're seeing
pictures of several disturbances just in
the last several minutes we should tell
you the official of protests there made
a protest was actually canceled by by
police because police say of the
presence and the behavior of what they
described as anarchist
we've been watching now over the last
several minutes a group of anywhere from
100 or more people of many of them dress
in black some have been setting fires
there you see police trying to trying to
put out sideways right there the made a
photo I mean it's really demonstrating
what kind of society they would like to
build if they had the opportunity or the
society they would like to destroy if
they had the opportunity every year in
Seattle they have made a violence and
people throw things through windows and
they protest against capitalism made AI
think is a good time for us to remember
let's say the hundred million people who
died due to communism over the course of
the 20th century I thought that the most
amazing picture is from Venezuela on may
day there was some woman holding a made
a bag while waiting in line for a loaf
of bread which pretty much sums up the
entire made a thing the left keeps
paying tribute tomato it's absurd May
Day is not a holiday May Day is a day of
tragedy if we're talking about the rise
of the communist Left which has killed
more people than all the religious wars
in history so that is that is worth
noting on the day after May okay well I
want to talk about President Trump and
whether he is being effective but we'll
get to that you have to go over to Daley
wire.com right now I have a
lot to talk about so we talked about The
Handmaid's Tale we're going to talk
about a piece of music that is obviously
ripped off for Star Wars we're going to
deconstruct the culture a little bit so
so much to talk about but you have to go
over to daily wire.com to become a
subscriber $8 a month gets you that
subscription annual subscription gets
you a copy of Jeremy borings the arroyo
fictional film set on the southern
border all about the people using me the
drug cartel is using the borders a
thoroughfare for drugs and human
trafficking go over to Daley wired.com
right now become a subscriber watch the
rest of the show live and then on
Thursday you can be part of the massive
incredible tremendous mailbag that will
make your life so much better in every
way you will win big league daily
wire.com go over and check it out we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
Oh